okay hello everyone welcome to a design
review for functionality for world
language 13.1 which is hopefully coming
out soon
um i believe we have a very busy live
streaming day today it looks like we're
four live streams scheduled
so i have a busy day every day but uh
this is going to be a visibly busy day
perhaps
um
okay we have started in on calculus and
algebra last time and i think we got
down to
this
section about implicit d and so on
that correct we had gone through these
things at the top here right yeah yeah
okay
and implicitly i think it'd be really
good if i mean there's a lot of stuff
from adam here maybe we should ask adam
to join
yeah please do can we do that yeah
can some
go find him please
yes
yeah
thank you
um
okay
so is this in the system or do i need to
look at the source code for implicit d
do do we think we finished with implicit
i mean in for for reference pages you
always need to look at the source
uh for implementation you can use
prototype build
that's what i'm using
yeah
okay
oops okay so implicitly we had started
talking about last time as i recall yes
are we have we finished or not
well
more or less we sort of you know we kind
of ran out of time so
okay let's take a look at it again
okay
so
the assumption comes first here
that's a special case
normally the function that you're going
to differentiate comes first
show me a non-special case sorry show me
a non-special case all these ones here
seem to be of these special cases
now only the first one is the special
case
the rest of them are the general case
see that's a function there of both x
and
you sorry this
okay
what are you computing i mean don't
if this is a special case for goodness
sake don't leave the documentation with
it
well the vendor thinks that that's
they're very important then our you know
well and speak up
yes so um the point here is that people
require this all the time
um so just explain to me what okay
this is
this is literally saying the function y
y
as a function of x with this constraint
yes
okay so now what's this here
you would get the same result as the
first one if you said implicit d
y comma and then the rest that's up
there in the first example yes
okay the second derivative of
okay so hold on let me look at this for
a second
okay
this has four arguments
this has three arguments yes
and there are an implicit y as the first
argument
okay basically saying y is the first
argument yes
okay so then if i take this
and i were to
explicitly run this implicit d
where i say here
y comma that that should be same as
exactly okay so explain to me
okay so
this is the derivative of y with respect
to x where the y that i am
differentiating with respect to x
is this first thing here yes yes okay so
if i said 2y for example i would get
that yes
i personally think the first example
should be this
and i think we should then we should say
you know alternatively you can
i don't know i would just use this no no
i think that's fine steven i think that
i think the vendor's point is that this
is how it's often presented in a
calculus textbook fine fine we can go to
that as example two or three or
something right yeah sure
because
you're saying you're differentiating
this with this constraint
and this is the dependent variable and
that's the independent variable is that
correct that's correct yes
okay
so now my only question is when you give
okay you've got the thing and its
constraint other functions that have a
thing and a constraint
um like all the optimization functions
how do they present their arguments
well the first is the objective second
is the constraint and the third is the
how what does constraint meant well i
thought it was called constrainment
what's it called what's it called
uh minimize
no but i i wasn't okay all right so if
we look at minimize for example okay
um
no you see that's that's wrong that's
not what there yeah we're trying to go
we want to go away from that form okay
no no no no no no no no don't hide it
okay so what are you talking about we're
going to go away from that forum with
this that was in an earlier era
okay roger yeah
yeah this is the mistake we've made too
many times before let's do this a little
bit more carefully all right
this is not a we're going to make up
charting stuff because we didn't like
the way that fund list plot functions
worked
let's understand what it is that we're
making
design incompatible and the answer is
minimize has the function and the
constraint
right in the list so what functions
don't work that way this is a little bit
different in the sense that there's a
bound variable there's no bound
variables here
bound variable in which case in in the
sense that you have a um
a dependent variable y
i'm sorry in in this case here for
minimizer in the case for implicit d
implicit d
okay
let me understand this in a bit more
detail okay we've got minimize
what other optimization functions do we
have and how do they deal with their
function and constraints no no they all
minimize and minimize
and find minimum
all work the same way
they have the same syntax so you can
flip between them what they don't do the
same way is that some of them have
special needs like the numeric functions
might need initial values
okay i understand okay where do those
put those
well it's different
so
roger but what you're saying is when
there is a constraint like this
all the minimum this is what i've
remembered the minimization functions
have the function followed by the
constraint in a list is that correct yes
okay now which functions you're saying
you want to go away from that which
functions have already gone away
uh convex optimization okay that was the
thing i was trying to remember okay so
let's take a look at how that works
oh god
okay so that has a function constraints
and variables
yes
okay
now
and admittedly i have to say implicit d
it wouldn't be the end of the world if
it had
so the constraints and the constrained
variables the bound variables there in a
group
yeah well let's let's talk about this i
mean why did we change that for convex
optimization why do we want f and cons
not to be in a list
it's awkward to package them up because
const is themselves usually very
complicated and you want to sort of
construct them separately fair enough
okay so basically the point is i mean
clearly if it's called cons in the early
days we we worked mostly on very small
problems no no i understand roger the
the point you're making is the
constraints are usually big pile of
constraints absolutely
the thing you're optimizing the f is
usually comparatively small yes
and we're seeing that again here in the
implicit d where the thing you're quotes
not optimizing but differentiating is
just y which is sort of small compared
to the constraint which you know the
curve which is bigger somehow right
okay let's let's go through this again
okay
it is unconvincing to me that just
because cons is big
i understand you know
you know we could write convex
you know optimization of
you know
x plus y comma big if we wanted to comma
x y
i mean in other words there doesn't seem
to me to be anything obviously
obviously wrong with
packaging those in a list
well right
i mean i i'm trying to understand why
did we make the decision to not package
in the list because the fact that this
thing can be big
is some
i think that it's a i've heard
complaints over the years many times and
this was just now we're working
intensely in optimization
and this was a low risk thing to do for
convex optimization i understand okay so
the question is for implicit d
you know
to me the very fact that i was confused
here
about this
is an argument for packaging those
things in a list because that way you
see it's not packaged okay it's the pure
constraint
i'm not certain i mean
by the way did adam join us
yeah he's you know great
um
does adam have an opinion about this
he probably just joined yes oh
no you don't have an opinion okay
then
adam just joined so he's missing a
little bit of contact
okay
all right
all right then
okay so we've got oh boy
how is this case not ambiguous if you
don't package these in a list
how is this case where it's a vera args
function not ambiguous
i think that
well there's the first three is probably
always required right so
yes but they're not always required look
at this case here if i say equation
comma y comma so this wasn't because has
to be an equation that recognizes by by
having had the equal
or list of equations
no
just just an equation so this is this is
a a particular k for one equation
which is different from all the other
ones
and but in this case here
i don't understand isn't the equation
i don't understand how can this be
represented by a single equation because
it's on a line i see because the case
doesn't it's not supported in that first
syntax this says eqn not eqn
okay i understand
i'm not sure here
so
okay so in this case here
what does this mean
these are the dependent variables i know
but how can there be
aren't you looking at the
variation you're looking at the
variation of this quantity
with this constraint
as you vary those variables is that
right
is that right i mean it's delta
you know
so
so the
you're looking at the derivative of the
first of the first thing
with respect to x the last thing and y
and z are are functions of of x
but how do they enter
so they are they are function of x that
are defined by by the system of
equations
so so i see so the point is you're
varying that single parameter x and
you're asking how does this vary when
you're on this curve and what why do you
need to know these is that just because
you need to know what is the i mean
could we not deduce these in a typical
case
no there can be parameters
okay fine so those are the things that
are but but explain to me
those are the things that are supposed
to be varying
i'm a little confused here those are the
things that are implicitly as you change
x
with this constraint
these are things which are considered to
vary as you vary x
containing this constraint whereas a
parameter a
you know you can change x however you
want
but um
uh
it's a constant yeah but it's a constant
right
sandra is making the point on the
livestream that convex optimization
always has the constraint whereas
minimize does not that is a good point
right that's correct roger and others
yes yes it is
okay so
again i'm asking
okay the dependent variable list there's
a single argument for the dependent
variables but the independent variables
you could have a long sequence of x one
x two x three as vera varax correct it
sort of follows the d
i i understand that i'm just asking the
questions i'm trying to understand is
that yes syntax and and what adam is
saying is it's never an ambiguous syntax
because the equation argument which is
by the way not a single equation as we
see here it can be a list of equations
as we see here right
but that doesn't support that shorter
syntax
so the shorter syntax is just for for a
single equation and the derivative of
of the
dependent variable
rather than an arbitrary expression so
it's it's just a shortcut that's
somewhat different than in the syntax
and all the other ones no no i
understand that's because in this case
as you're describing that can define a
you know a line on a sphere and so on as
opposed to just a thing where there is a
single
you know where there's a single variable
that is that is where that where that
argument
no i'm now confused again well this
argument has to be a single variable
right
right okay look look there's there's a
binary decision here i mean i think we
understand how all of this works but for
one thing which is should the equations
be in a list or not
my tendency probably is to say they
should not be in a list because they are
so necessary to the whole story
what do you mean by list i mean there
are no no no no no i mean they should be
in a list with the f oh i see okay okay
so my feeling is that what you've got
here is right
that they shouldn't be in a list with f
okay so i mean anybody want to disagree
with that i mean obviously this is what
you set up so i'm agreeing with you at
this point okay the only disagreement i
have is that i think the very first
example should not be this example we
can fix that
yeah so you just want to y yeah adam
later don't put a single y there put two
y or something okay fine two y is good
idea sure fine
yeah and then then you're saying then
write out the words
you're saying derivative of two y
or whatever you want of y plus one or
something
you know as
i mean it's not really with respect
what would you say what are the words
okay so so
it is with respect to x actually
okay so just tell me the words with
respect to x
and then how do you describe the why
that's there how do you what do you say
that
why
is satisfy that equation
yeah or why is implicit function defined
by this equation no no no no just tell
me the word
okay it's the derivative of two y plus
one
where
uh where x
with respect to x
where y varies according to the equation
blah blah blah or is constrained by the
equation blah blah blah is that right i
think that's the right words yes yes yes
constrained definitely not there right
yeah no no no so so where so okay so
we should capture those words but but
that that's basically what we have to
say and that's probably what we have to
say in the original that's what we have
to say in the example that's probably
what we have to say in the in the box at
the top
makes sense
okay
great let's move on that's great i've no
other further comments on this looks
good
i'm sorry you guys are a little bit
victim of the fact that i've got four
design review-ish meetings or something
today so i want to move through this
quickly
yeah okay
integrate change variables let's look at
this now
okay so this i think is going to bring
up the the the horrors of
inactive things right
yes not sure we're going to be able to
solve that here and i think you should
make this experimental
we want to make it yes that's fine
okay
so just let me give a sense of this so
this is
change variables in the inactivated
integral
i mean to me
really why isn't it an arrow here
right so the equal sign is more
symmetrical we can do it the other way
but then your constraint give
the x in terms of
t
i'm sorry what are you doing here in
other words
is it the case okay so you're saying
change variables
to the variable t and this is the i this
is the relationship exactly and that's a
little more flexible that's the other
three people that's the reason i mean
just the way people write it out in the
calculus course i'm just trying to look
at the typical calculus student trying
to use this function okay question
question
if i just gave the integrand here
if i were
you know let's imagine that this
function worked differently and it
didn't have in that wait a minute it
didn't have inactivated integrals in it
you just gave the integrand now you're
going to complain about limits but let's
talk about that in a second okay
if if we didn't have if it was an
indefinite integral would that work
we had that design initially the problem
is
that you need to support all the
syntaxes that are there for integrals
right and now you're going to make up
new syntaxes and you can't flip
you can't you can't flip it basically
it's just
it it it's it's a big mess
okay somehow it's very and you're gonna
have all these things yeah okay fine
fine so that's not that's nasty
very very nice you here
but now we've also we plan to make this
work
you know if it's not underway to make it
work for and integrate an asymptotic
integrator it really works as an example
problem okay okay great
so
so in other words
we view
and this is part of the design of
inactive that that the inactive
integrate is a declarative statement
yeah
okay and all of these things are
declarative statement they're problem
description languages
all right suppose let's see cartesian to
polar how does it know what the names of
the variables are
it knows the coordinate systems
underneath oh but but you already have
them right whether you can know the x
and y from the integral
no no no no no no no no no no
steven has a point here like which order
is it yeah you know is it i see so we
should probably some way to give the
order we have two well what what is the
thing for changing coordinate systems
how does that work how does that the
what is that thing called um
coordinate chart what is this yeah yeah
sure
data coordinate chart data problem right
so how does that work and how does that
give the order of you can give them oh
yeah yeah yeah you can give them there
okay
can you open that page stephen it
actually has a notation for that okay
that's fine
i mean i think that there is a way
um
no a good catch that's that's a really
good point so
let's see where that notation is
not shown there
i think it's in a different coordinate
transform data oh probably that yeah
uh really i don't know yeah it's hard to
know right we need to look we can design
that though because i could
you know so so what i assume that it is
or what we want is something like
you know cartesian list x comma y
and then we say polar r comma theta or
if i wanted row comma phi
you know yeah i understand i think we're
going to have to go back and revisit
this chart stuff i mean this is a this
is a reasonable first syntax yeah but
but you're right we got we gotta sort of
extend it in the way that you describe i
just i should have caught that
but i think what we're gonna need is a
symbolic
you know
description of a coordinate system so in
other words just like when we were
designing this
there is a way in the end that the h's
or whatever you know metric tensors
like this which we pull out
and and that has to be a sub value of
this symbolic object that represents the
coordinate system the thing that's going
to get tricky
is this coordinate system is going to be
associated with these named variables
and this is another can of worms with
formal variables versus bound variables
and so on potentially yes but here we
have concrete variables that we want to
go from and go to i understand
sandra on our live stream is asking
about um integrals that can't be done
like integrate yes
this example in the applications where
you show an integral which cannot be
done without the transformation by
integrate right now but once you apply
transformation so basically the basic
point is it supports both then activated
integrate and and
yeah absolutely yes oh yes oh yes that's
that's the design
we have to fix the type type setting
there it's bold there yeah i know it's a
fix okay what about a hold what about
integrate change variables hold of
integrated whatever that as well
uh
i would do that as well fine
i would do that i would do hold form i
mean i would just make it a courtesy
where you know you translate it from
whatever was given to the same form of
holding so to speak on the output
okay
this is a function that's been long yeah
i mean long awaited yeah we definitely
need this
um
i don't have a problem with this i mean
i i think that this we need more
discussion about this inactive thing we
should make this experimental but i
think this looks good otherwise
thank you um and also that needs to be
italics by the way and lowercase c
right or whatever it is however that
works right
those are the objects yep um
okay these solve change variables so now
you can probably guess how this is going
to go
well let's hope i can
if it's right i can guess
okay
um
we have an even more elaborate way of
describing
systems of differential equations
than we have of integrals
what the heck is all of this
okay so that is
i'm a little confused here
so let me look at this again
okay this says i want this to end up
with this independent variable this
integration variable
okay
i'm not even going to ask what happens
in change of variables with respect to
constants of integration and so on and
clearly integrate change variables for
an indefinite integral might give you a
mathematically different object
correct than in because because of the
change of the constant of integration
i'm making sense
when you change variables right
go ahead yes yes that's i agree with
that that in fact it's a little
ambiguous for the indefinite integral
case
but then people required so
okay no no i understand but you've got
to explain that in documentation and put
it in possible issues and so on that the
thing you get
right by changing variables might not be
the same
you know
um
you know might not be the be the same
thing
okay now here you've got an independent
variable dependent variable and the
transformation
question is it obvious that you want to
put the transformation last as opposed
to before the t
particularly given this case because
this is the main event
here
and one could imagine some future more
ai world so to speak where you could
drop this thing just like solve in
principle you could drop you know and
solve x squared minus one equals zero or
something you could drop the x
did you understand my question
i think i would establish what t is the
transformation doesn't make sense that's
my view
so you need to see what is and then you
need to okay but it's a bit unfortunate
you've got two variables here yes yes i
know but i think that
i think that that way we kind of first
go
we kind of more or less go all the way
the d solve kind of syntax and questions
is it the case that you might want to
make a change of variables here
where probably not where you leave y the
same but you're changing x to t
i think it should work if you just i
don't know no no no no i'm not asking
questions no but i don't think we need a
separate syntax for it i don't think
it's that
you don't think it's that common no no
no
explain for a second so i mean let's say
i think that even if you didn't if even
if it's
you know in this case in principle you
could have had y in the thing that comes
out but that's like confusing okay hold
on hold on hold on let's say i'm making
a change of variables in a pde from you
know cartesian to spherical yes usually
you don't change the name of the
dependent variable when you do that
but i think it's confusing well maybe it
is but but people don't do it i mean
they but then they spent endless pages
of explaining that what they really did
was meaning this
right
maybe so but but i'm still asking the
question if people are going to want to
make that change of variables but they
can they can reproduce that case if they
want to put you you to be why
it should be okay
well i mean clearly you're arguing
you're you're making me argue against
myself because i was saying for the
implicit d you want to give the
explicitly the y as the first argument
right
yeah which is the same type of thing
yeah
more or less
more or less
it's just this has an awful lot of i
mean okay
are you sure about this this is going to
be lists in general the user is going to
be a list and t's are going to be a list
and so on right systems or pdes
it could whoever's making clicking
sounds in the background try and mute
that will be adam i think yeah okay
um
well fair enough
um
does this work with eigenvalue equations
as well and what does it do with those
but there's some kind of eigenvalues
you know we didn't think of that but
there's no reason because it's the same
change of variables
that the eigenvalue doesn't there's no
tangling up of the argument structure
no i think we could have that's as a
first argument just as a d what is the
function again
the
value of the eigen system
nd et cetera et cetera
you need an operator there that's the
only thing
um wait a minute
all right
okay so here so there's a domain here
yeah
but that we can have that in uh
in in diesel and nd servers also
okay so that domain when you do a change
of variables what happens to the domain
so okay let me let's start off with the
basic question in integrate
right you clearly are dealing with
although you don't show an example of
that yes there's one in the there's a
section of regions in the scope which
has examples for regions
but i don't think you get back a region
necessarily we might have just wait
wait a second wait so much sure
okay
so
for goodness sake show a region well
okay so there's a region
but
can't you do an integral am i am i wrong
to think
that if i do an integral hold on one
second here um
can't i just say integrate
you know x to the fourth x y
element of disk yes
okay great
okay so now
if i
turn this
into
inactivate
and by the way you should show people in
the documentation how to do that
how to announce i don't think you should
just do inactive of the integral because
like now you're in inactivated elements
i know so so then please show people
when when you do this don't
i i know i know i know i got it wrong
but when you show people in the
documentation can you type out yes
blah blah blah we should do that okay
rather than showing just that integral
there
okay
um
okay so inactive integrate which is
perfectly civilized to write that
okay so there we've got that
so now i say
um integrate
change variables
and now i'm going to say
um i want to change that
to
uh
r theta
um
and how do i do this now and then i give
um
uh i'm going to say cartesian
cartesian arrow polar
what happened
so you have
a disc
did i get this wrong
looks okay to me
how would i write okay so there's a bug
here
i mean
how would i write the cartesian to polar
thing as an equation so what i would
write here is x squared plus y squared
equals r squared
and you know y over x
equals arctan
theta
am i right if i i mean you could just
give it x equal to r cosine and y equal
to r sine well i want to do this i want
to do that that's fine
okay i better save this file okay so
this isn't right i mean this is this you
agree that this should work yes
um i've
you know so this is um so i investigated
this to you know quite extensively 20
years ago
when we introduced boole and other
things and ultimately
these things when you have complicated
regions
most people pick a change of variables
based on
the function
but the region and the function may not
agree on the symmetries
so
i'm saying like let's say that you have
something that's not particularly polar
in the region you're going to get things
that are basically unresolvable you're
going to get transcendental
inequalities that need to be eliminated
and we can't do it
i understand but i mean you know you
can't just splat over you just fall over
and play dead here no no no no no i
think that this case should have worked
so yeah okay but but let me ask this
question but i'm just saying that there
are these these ultimate there are these
limits people think the change of
variables is so like a holy grail and it
isn't particularly i understand
especially what right
you could it could get incredibly weird
yeah
i mean it's a it's a giant sort of
algebraic varieties twisting into other
things and just yeah i don't even know
what this is it's like
it's like mappings it's like there's
some like conformal mapping right is one
thing for you know in two dimensions but
generalizing that is really a mess yep
okay so
just to understand when you give a
specification like this
that can be a short form for presumably
you know
coordinate chart data of
blah blah
of you know i'm making this up but it's
some you know something like this
whatever it is
right that's a good point to explain it
that way too
right and that then this thing becomes
you know
and then it turns into potentially a set
of equations right which is what you're
going to use ultimately under the hood
right devendra adams
yes
okay
well now
okay fine so i think i understand this
but
clearly as roger is saying you know if i
give a complicated implicit region here
the transformation of that under this
change of variables might be a really i
mean do we do we even have a function
that takes a region
and changes variables for that region
yeah
we tried also built in return it's kind
of not built to doing this very
intensive reduced kind of work in a way
we need to
sort domains and parameters and all kind
of stuff so we actually had to
do some of it by hand the
the transformations
well okay but but but i'm asking this
question
there is a there is a you can get
formulas from regions is that what you
mean so there is uh
what is it called transform
transform region is that no no no no we
just introduced it it's called um region
convert yes read and convert yes
okay but so what i'm asking is so we use
that extensively under the hood but no
we don't give you sort of a change of
variables for regions because the most
of them have no variables
i understand that i understand that but
if i'm saying
okay so
you've got a region you put down a
coordinate system on that region in
order to be able to do an integral for
example
right
um although
right
we do something that's smarter than that
most of the time
i i realize that for regions when but
the problem is to say it's x to the
fourth you need to quote that in terms
of variables
yes
i mean in in our infra calculus project
for the physics project we hope to
transcend that issue but that is a
different story and for the future where
we're just operating but we don't invent
variables yet
um and where we just have the the base
space switches in this case a limiting
hyper graph thing but basically like let
me just summarize it what we do for re
so underlying regions if you take
something like disk we have multiple
representations we have a multiple
implicit multiple parametric
representations different functions want
different forms and are differently
capable so to make regions work across
the system we need to have a
multi-representational system i
understand optimization for instance
want implicit forms it really likes
inequalities inequalities yeah
integration
you know is only really defined for
parametric forms so even if differential
geometry they allow for implicit regions
they say well you know locally you can
parametrize it because of the implicit
function theory
okay but
look there's two things that are going
on here there is the change of variables
affecting this okay affecting the
measure
for example affecting you know
for an integral effect in the measure
just transforming the you know you the
tooth right so the only the other
difference is
when you change variables
the
region
is described differently like for
example in this case what if you look at
if you look at the
yes it should be yes it's r equals one
this should this should turn into
let's just understand what the output
should be here it should be integrate
of
x to the fourth becomes r
you know r sine theta whatever it is to
the fourth
if i'm not mistaken yes yes
thank you yes okay right i you know i
don't do these things by hand
um
uh okay and then r probably from the
measure
i mean
the jacobian basically yes okay so what
what is the jacobi name
in this case is this is going to be r
from one to one oh no no let's say
well if it was a circle i see this sort
of disc it would be r zero to one and
then theta zero to two pi yes and you
wanna factor
yeah
factor of what of r for jacobian of the
transformation yeah all right but then
theta
goes from zero to two pi yes yes yes
okay fine so that's what we should see
in this case yes
okay
so so really the description which is
interesting is we will break out of we
will transform from this
geometric description to this
essentially algebraic description but
that's also geometric description
because that's a r theta lives in a
rectangle so what we could say here
if you're saying what we could do
instead is to come out with r theta
you know
element of
uh
you know rectangle
you know whatever it would be zero to
one i mean that that's probably zero
zero
one
two pi or something is that right right
give or take okay so you've got a choice
of which of those you want to do right
and people might prefer the iterated
integral because that's the way things
are typically well i know that but i
mean that's a choice you can make but
maybe it's an option yeah maybe here's
yes so whether you've tried
because you might also want to preserve
this that might also be useful thing to
do so what i'm asking is a different
question
in this transformation from disk to
rectangle that would seem to me to be a
useful function its own right having
nothing to do with integrals
right
and that's
you know
right i mean that's changing the
description of a region
which you're also doing in region
convert
well now region convert just gives you a
different representation of the same
region transformed region transforms
regions i understand but this is a
different description of the same region
again
no it's a different region okay all
right fine but so kind of transformed
region okay fine but what i'm saying is
this this functionality should exist
independent of it being diggable out of
integrate change variables
do you agree yeah yeah it's called
transformed region okay but i mean in
but does it do it right now
yes
so i can i could do this transformation
yeah i mean it doesn't do much for for
yeah it tries to pursue what it's not
doing this case it's not doing the case
well no it's not doing that case okay i
think it doesn't have special cases
stored for
non-linear transformations it does a lot
of things special for affine and linear
fractional because it's good
so this is probably the place to build
out
this kind of you know
this kind of functionality and whatever
it is that we're doing with cartesian to
polar should work for this too
right uh probably
i think so yeah i think so because look
there's no names of their
no names are variables that's not a bad
idea actually
yes we probably should
okay fine then that would do this and
that would provide that functionality
and then we're doing now just so i
understand getting out the jacobian
that also should be a factorable thing
to get out the jacobian of the
transformation of the of the you know
cartesian to polar whatever and that
presumably you can get from coordinate
chart data yes yes
okay
um
okay all right well this looks good all
right anything else on this
let's do some maybe
i'm sorry
oh let's do some i mean
no no i understand these ones here this
looks straight i mean the syntax is
there's nothing complicated about this
no no it's just what we did for d
solvent version uh 13.2 has now been
done in 13.1 for our salt etc just does
it doesn't it doesn't get weird in any
way no it works perfectly and
we just tell me the syntax please yeah
so it you just need to say that
something's in vectors and there should
even be an example
in marked blue somewhere
just uh hopefully
they are somewhere over there oh i hate
this
yeah i hate this so much i hate it so
much
i mean i understand this is what we're
doing hopefully we will have some summit
discussion about symbolic vectors soon
i hope that's being i mean that's a post
13.1 thing but it needs to get scheduled
well i'm not a fan but whatever i mean
this is this is consistent with what
we're doing elsewhere so it's exactly
the same yes and distribution come on
you can do better that please don't use
capital letter variables we tell users
don't do that please don't do that in
documentation okay sure and you know the
rules about this kind of documentation
and how we should be setting it up yes
okay we're gonna we're gonna look at
this and then
uh then we're gonna have to wrap this
meeting and continue this at a different
time but we we need to try to get
through these this week so um
i don't know when it's going to get
rescheduled
but sometime the next
day or two
all right let's look at this this i
think should be straightforward he says
famous losses if you had function
then you recommend this last time so we
just directly just have
so some of the residues of all residues
now what if i want just the residues
within a particular contour yeah if
well that doesn't make really good
constraints and that should work then a
strange around here
oh sorry adam's here so he knows
okay so this is using the listed version
which is probably right because again
it's an optional constraint
okay looks good
i i think this looks fine i don't have
an objection to this although i am
asking the question if i want around you
know the unit disc
can i give
is there a convenient way to give the
constraint of the unit disk
i think you could you could say x
x or owns
right
off of z less than equal one so no i i
know that
geometric language probably won't work
here that well because we are talking
about complex variable
so geometry deals with real variables
i see what you're saying okay so the
unit disk okay so that raises the
question of
uh
the
a complex disk object
that represents a disk in the complex
plane
different from disc
in the you know a real geometric disc
is that right or is there a different
way to think about it
do you understand my question yeah yeah
so
i mean we really didn't want to build
complex geometry yet
geometry but you could say reezy
comma mz elementor disk and it would
still be correct
bluff
yeah
or we could say that we treat 2d
geometry as the complex plane
yeah
well i mean you'd have to say z is an
element of disk and then that that's
kind of going down a slippery slope yes
but it's not ridiculous i mean you know
it's not as if
it's not as if that's changing right i
mean you know the mapping of complex
numbers to the you know
to the sort of cartesian plane is a
pretty well established thing it doesn't
have to be that way but it is a
well-established way to think about
complex numbers yes and it's certainly
the one that we use in a very
fundamental way in the complex you know
in our data types and so on yeah from a
topology point of view complex numbers
add nothing
it's just a real plane
yeah but
right but i mean that so
i kind of think we should be thinking
about you know for this particular case
this is a very very common case where
you say i mean and also in the end we
want named contours presumably
like you know the bromich contour or
whatever else it is
making sense
no not yet but yes
no i understand but but in principle
that contour
is i mean that contour depends on the
function depends on the positions of the
poles yes it's like to the right of all
the poles yes
um
but we could imagine
that thing being a construct in
two-dimensional planar geometry
where instead of giving poles we say
here's our inventory of um
uh you know avoidance points
go work with this yes but we i mean we
really don't want to introduce that now
i mean i we are thinking about that
we're planning that but i really this
this just is like a whole can of stuff
that's exploding if you want to bring
that up now no no i i understand okay so
we're not doing that yet all right i'm
just going to look at one more thing and
then we're going to i mean we're not
we're not actually going to look at one
more thing but we're going to
um there's just one more thing the
structure that is oh sorry oh sorry
no it's not a quick thing and i i just
want to get some sense of how horrifying
it's going to be
that's not horrifying
of course not
it's brilliant i'm sure
um
okay that's what i thought it was
oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah i mean i just worry so much about
all the other random things that might
or might not support this like array
plot for example
it's matrixqueue
nice
yeah we ever made a list of things we
tried to keep it as complete as possible
but we might have missed
no i mean the core framework that we
built with rob and jose
does just that like if there is a
special operation it uses it otherwise
it turns it into a normal matrix yes i
see
yeah it'll all work all the opportunity
much faster in many cases because we
we know it's permutation so it goes much
much faster and how do you pack it in i
see so that okay okay this isn't going
to be so horrifying actually yeah it's a
lot of work has gone designed this and
what we have
it's quite lightweight i mean it doesn't
affect the user that much
and it's scalable to large matrices it
might even so if
if i take an upper triangular matrix
and i transpose it
okay
so if i take that upper triangular
matrix yes
and i say transpose
lovely
array plot that
yes
it is very well tested function it's
already gone through qa etc
a lot of work has gone into this already
why do i feel that as you as you okay
i mean we don't do that q a q a looks
like after we review it but this time we
have no but the scans of things that
stephen will spot is sort of i don't
think it's on qa's radar particularly
you know like entanglements far out in
the language yes right
yeah i mean like i don't know how all
these work we need to review these but
this should be a fairly fast review good
i would predict half an hour
um
i also would like to ask the question
how does this relate to data structures
and should there be a data structure
corresponding to upper triangular matrix
i think yes
let's talk that let's have that
discussion next time okay fine i'm
putting that on the radar okay thanks
guys okay people following these live
streams we are actually about to enter
another design review live stream
so if you want to see you there